CFD zu diesem Mittel gegriffen also
jetzt gleich eine Aktuelle Stunde
zu möglichen Stromausfällen im Winter
jetzt haben wir allerdings noch die
letzten Fragen hier in der Fragestunde
nach wie vor steht hier zur Beantwortung
auf der Regierungsbank die
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin aus
dem
Wirtschaftsministerium Franziska
Brandner hier zu Antwort und wir hören
mal rein
es geht im Moment um die Frage zum
Zeitpunkt der Ausrufung des Gas
Notfallplans 3 das ist die Frage hierzu
und die Antwort jetzt von Franziska
Brandner weicheren
[Musik]
wissen Sie ich bin wirklich stolz darauf
dass ich in der Demokratie lebe und ich
werde sie verteidigen gegen ihre
Angriffe bis aufs Letzte
aber wenn Sie die Antwort auf die Frage
interessiert gebe ich Ihnen gerne
sie haben darauf nochmal nachgefragt
nach welchen Kriterien die
Bundesnetzagentur entscheidet die sind
gesetzlich festgelegt wir haben in der
Zwischenzeit durch die Bundesnetzagentur
sehr viele Vorbereitungen getroffen es
ist leider nicht möglich regional das
genau vorherzusehen aber es werden
überall in allen Regionen die Gesprächen
zur Vorbereitung geführt und zusätzlich
das möchte ich hier noch mal betonen
werden wir die schwimmenden LNG
Terminals bei uns haben die uns ab 2023
auch hier natürlich helfen aus dieser
schwierigen Situation herauszukommen und
ich bin deswegen zuversichtlich dass wir
das gemeinsam schaffen das ist unsere
Aufgabe und
entsprechend hat sich die
Bundesnetzagentur sehr gut
vorbereitet im Ausschuss wurde es heute
auch entsprechend noch mal dargelegt und
wir halten uns dabei auch an die
europarechtlichen und unsere
nationalstaatlichen Vorgaben wie in
dieser gasmangelage wenn sie eintreffen
sollte gehandelt wird
eine letzte Nachfrage von Dr Kraft zu
und dann ist hier Frage schon
vielen Dank ich wundere mich
ob Ihre Sicherheit sie haben mir gerade
in der Antwort auf meine letzte Frage
gesagt dass sie überhaupt nicht wissen
wie viel private
Gastanker an diesen LG Terminals Anlagen
anlanden werden weil das gar nicht ihre
Aufgabe ist jetzt verlassen sich darauf
dass da viele viele kommen werden um
damit die gasmagenlage nicht eintritt
was ihr eben als sehr unwahrscheinlich
betrachtet haben also woher nehmen sie
die gewisse dass diese vielen vielen
LNG-Tanker kommen werden konträr zur
aktuellen Marktsituation für lngas auf
den Weltmärkten und regiert einfach im
bmwk nur noch das Prinzip Hoffnung
sie können einfach
ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass wir
schon aktuell kein Gas über nonstream 1
bekommen
unsere Unternehmen aber mit aller
Unterstützung die wir haben trotzdem die
Gasversorgung sicherstellen dass wir
zusätzlich zu der aktuell ja schon
weiter laufenden Gasversorgung die
Speicher voll haben dass wir ab Januar
die LNG Terminals so weit ready haben
dass die Schiffe die ja jetzt schon auf
dem Weg zu uns sind auch anlanden können
und die Schiffe die werden durch die
Marktteilnehmer geordert wir leben in
einer freien Marktwirtschaft wo die
Unternehmen in der Lage sind dies zu
machen und wenn sie dabei finanzielle
Schwierigkeiten haben dann sind wir bei
der Frage wie der Staat sie dabei
finanziell unterstützt das war der ganze
erste Teil dieser Fragestunde das ist
die Verantwortung der wir uns stellen
aber nicht dass wir jetzt jedes einzelne
Schiff beordern das machen zum Glück
unsere unternehmen und dabei
unterstützen wir sie
vielen Dank Frau Staatssekretärin damit
ist die Fragestunde beendet ich bedanke
mich bei Ihnen ganz herzlich für das
auszahlungsvermögen und bei den anderen
Staatssekretären dafür dass sie jetzt
gewartet haben und nicht mehr zum
zugekommen der Übung Folgen werden die
bisher nicht behandelten Fragen
schriftlich beantwortet ich rufe auf die
von der afd-fraktion beantragte aktuelle
Stunde zu der Antwort der
Bundesregierung auf die Frage Nummer 7
der Fragestunde zur Geschäftsordnung hat
sich
Brandner gemeldet
für die afd-fraktion wir sind gemäß
Paragraph 42 der Geschäftsordnung
beantrage ich die Herbeirufung des
zuständigen Ministers für Wirtschaft und
Klima Robert Habeck wir wissen der ist
ab 16 Uhr entschuldigt aber eine gute
Dreiviertelstunde wird er noch Zeit
haben im Plenum zu verbringen die
Brisanz der Lage und die Tatsache dass
er habe ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen
was dabei lernen kann bei der Debatte
begründet diesen Antrag
vielen Dank Herr Brandner darüber kann
das Haus abstimmen wer dafür ist den
Herrn Bundesminister
Habeck herbeizuzituieren
das ist die afd-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das ist
SPD Bündnis
weil Enthaltung der Union damit ist der
Antrag Herr Brantner abgelehnt wir
kommen jetzt zur aktuellen Stunde erster
Redner ist der Kollege Tino propalla
afd-fraktion
hört die AFD hatte diese aktuelle Stunde
kurzfristig beantragt aus der
Fragestunde heraus jetzt also hier die
eine Gruppe ab für die AFD
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute ich denke es gibt kein
wichtigeres Thema zu einer aktuellen
Stunde weil genau dieses Thema Blackout
und wir haben es ja heute in der nicht
beantworteten Frage der Bundesregierung
zur Frage 7 was Blackout angeht auch
gesehen und das ist das was die Bürger
umtreibt das ist das was dem Mittelstand
umtreibt was die Wirtschaft umtreibt die
Industrie umtreibt und dann kommt
natürlich noch das verheerende Szenario
dazu was gestern mit dem Sabotage
Angriff auf nordstream 1 und 2 passiert
ist und das laute Schweigen der
Bundesregierung zeugte eigentlich davon
dass hier keine Antworten bis jetzt
gegeben werden und deshalb denke ich ist
es darüber wichtig dass wir hier in der
Plenardebatte auch darüber reden
zu den Hintergründen und Verantwortung
wissen wir aktuell wenig bis nichts eine
steht fest es richtet sich gegen
Deutschland gegen unsere Wirtschaft und
zeigt auch wie verwundbar wir sind in
Anbetracht der aktuellen Lage werde ich
mich nicht festlegen einen Schuldigen
hier heute zu benennen wie es bereits
der Spitzenpolitiker anderer Parteien
ihrer Fraktion ja bereits gemacht haben
für die steht ja schon fest russland hat
seine eigenen Leitung sabotiert und da
muss man wirklich die Frage stellen ob
sie dazu eigentlich auch stichhaltige
Beweise haben bevor sie solche
Behauptungen aufstellen und ich weiß
hier und heute nur dass viele Szenarien
denkbar jedoch nur einige wahrscheinlich
sind lassen Sie mich kurz auf ein paar
Fakten eingehen um dich selbst ein Bild
auch machen zu können
im August diesen Jahres fordert der
polenspräsident andre duda man solle
Nord Stream 2 abreißen gestern nach dem
vermeintliche Bilder von austretenden
Gas im Internet veröffentlicht wurden
kommentierte der polnische
Europaabgeordnete radioslav siekorski
und ehemaliger polnische Außenminister
sogleich auf Twitter danke USA und der
polnische Ministerpräsident Matthäus
marowietzki wird von der
Wirtschaftswoche bei der Einweihung
einer kompressorenstation der Baltic
pipe in der Nähe von Stettin zitiert die
Ära der russischen Vorherrschaft beim
Thema Gas geht zu Ende eine Ära die von
Erpressung Drohungen und zwang geprägt
war damit kann nun norwegisches Erdgas
über Dänemark nach Polen fließen schon
Anfang Februar diesen Jahres kündigte
der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten
Joe Biden an sollte Russland die Ukraine
angreifen werde es kein nordstream 2
mehr geben man werde dem einem Ende
setzen Nordstemmen auch daraufhin durch
den Bundeskanzler Olaf Schol zum
Sanktionsmittel eingesetzt die CDU und
davorsitzenden Herr Merz auch sie
forderte schon Sanktionen gegen
nordstream 1 im März die FDP-Fraktion
war ganz eifrig dabei nordstream 2 auch
abreißen zu wollen als Beschluss so viel
darf zu wie die Unterstützung zum
Mittelstand und Wirtschaft aussieht da
muss ihn ja wirklich gestern ein Herz
ausgegangen sein meine Damen und Herren
und zu allem Überfluss muss man sie auf
die Frage stellen die CIA warnte laut
aktueller Medienberichte die
Bundesregierung bereits im Sommer diesen
Jahres es könnte zu Angriffen auf
Pipelines und unterwasserkabeln kommen
und da muss die Frage erlaubt sein wenn
das so ist und wenn das so gewesen sein
sollte weshalb haben Sie nicht die
Bundesregierung oder die
parlamentarischen Vertreter unterrichtet
oder zum Beispiel auch dem
Verteidigungsausschuss und deshalb
spricht die Vorsitzende stark Zimmermann
vom Schuldigen Russland jetzt schon da
muss man die Frage widerstellen haben
sie mehr Erkenntnisse und warum liegen
diese im Parlament nicht vor warum
schweigen alle Vertreter aktuell der
Bundesregierung wie Bundeskanzler
Wirtschaftsminister Außenminister
Verteidigungsminister zu dieser
Situation kann die Sicherheit von
Deutschland und das fragen sich viele
Bürger und auch Unternehmer kann die
Sicherheit von Deutschland und Europa
noch gewährleistet werden oder folgen
ihrem Wirtschaftskrieg nun kriegerischer
Auseinandersetzung in weiteren Teilen
unseres Kontinents habe ich ihre Aufgabe
als Bundesregierung ist es doch die
kritische Infrastruktur zu schützen das
ist die Aufgabe der Bundesregierung wir
fordern deshalb eine schnelle und
lückenlose Aufklärung ohne
Vorverurteilung und wir fordern die
sofortige Reparatur die
schnellstmögliche Instandsetzung der
nordstream-leitungen hier geht es um
unserer Land und um unsere Bürger
und wie sie alle wissen und sehen werden
die Probleme vor denen wir stehen immer
und immer komplexer die galoppierende
Inflation die Stabilität unserer Währung
die fehlende Souveränität in der
Energieversorgung gerade jetzt sehen wir
all diese Probleme die sie alle hier in
diesem Haus aufgebaut haben die
Sicherung des Lebensunterhalts vieler
Bürger die nicht abnehmenden
Migrationsströme die noch dazu kommen
und nun auch noch Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur ohne die wir eigentlich
nicht existieren können wir brauchen
bezahlbare verfügbare und
grundlastfähige Energieversorgung auch
mit russischen Gas und das ist genau das
was unseren Wirtschaft und unsere
Wohlstand auch begründet hat diesen
Motor bringen Sie werte Bundesregierung
zügig und nachhaltig zum Stillstand und
deshalb
[Applaus]
sie erklären auch dass die Lieferung
schwerer Waffen in Kriegsgebiete
Konflikte beenden würde und machen sich
damit eines neuen stellvert
stellvertreterkrieges der USA schuldig
vor unserer Haustür und auf den Rücken
des ukrainischen des russischen und
wahrscheinlich bei deutschen Volkes und
deshalb klären sie lückenlos diesen
Anschlag auf auf die gaspipelions 1 und
2 beenden Sie den wirtschaftlichen
Interaktionen und schaffen Sie Frieden
auf dem Kontinent Europa vielen Dank
[Applaus]
der fraktions- und Parteivorsitzende der
AFD
fünf Minuten begrenzt ist und ich
künftige Zeitüberschreitungen nicht mehr
zulassen wer der Kollege
die Aktuelle Stunde eröffnet weil ja
auch die AFD diesen Antrag gestellt
hatte kurzfristig jetzt hören wir aus
den Rhein der Sozialdemokraten Tim und
gremmels erst Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie meine Damen und
Herren was wir hier gerade erlebt haben
waren Inszenierung der AFD wie kann es
denn sein dass aus dem Minderheitenrecht
sozusagen aus der Fragestunde bei einer
Nichtbeantwortung eine Frage zu einer
generieren zehn Minuten später hier der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der AFD hinkommen
kann und ein fertiges redelmann und
Skript vorliest das ist sozusagen ein
Missbrauch eines parlamentsrechtes ja
sie haben das zu Kenntnis genommen
wir haben das zu Geld ist genommen und
wir werden auch unsere Schlüssel draus
ziehen sie treten das Recht des
Parlaments mit Füßen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren erstens
zweitens ich sage Ihnen an dieser Stelle
ich sage Ihnen ich sage an dieser Stelle
die Regierungskoalition hatten heute
eine Aktuelle Stunde geplant wo wir ein
Signal setzen wollten Richtung Iran
Richtung der dort Demonstrierenden
Zivilgesellschaft die den Tod von einer
jungen Frau im Polizeigewahrsam zum
Thema hatte es wäre eine wichtige Signal
des deutschen Parlamentes gewesen
Richtung
Opposition im Iran und sie machen hier
ihre bill spielt hier meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das muss man
den Menschen draußen an den Bildschirm
auch mal deutlich sagen was Sinn und
Zweck dieser Geschichte ist und dann
haben sie sich eine Frage ausgesucht wo
Staatssekretärin Brandner doch völlig zu
Recht in ihrer Beantwortung gesagt hat
ob nun Nord Stream 1 und 2 Lex haben wie
diese Lecks entstanden sind ob das
Anschläge war wer die Anschläge wer
hätte dann Schlägen steckt dass das
völlig gleichgültig ist weil aus beiden
Pipelines aus der einen kam noch nie Gas
aus der anderen gab es seit Wochen kein
Gas mehr es ist völlig irrelevant wir
brauchen Nord Stream 1 und 2 nicht meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren und
warum brauchen wir die nicht weil wir
rechtzeitig Vorsorge weil wir
rechtzeitig Vorsorge betrieben haben als
Bundesregierung wir haben dafür gesorgt
nach dem 24 Februar nach dem Überfall
Russlands auf die Ukraine nach diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg haben wir
dafür gesorgt dass Vorsorge getrieben
wird wir haben die Lehren Gasspeicher
gefüllt meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
91% Füllstand soll Aktuellen Stunde ist
der heutige Stand das ist sozusagen das
was wir gemacht haben wir haben LNG
Terminals aus dem Boden gestampft im
wahrsten des Wortes im am 24 Februar gab
es das noch nicht am 21 Dezember ist
nach jetzigen Planungsstand die ersten
lng-terminals gehen ans Netz meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das macht
diese Bundesregierung das macht diese
Koalition meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren wir lassen Kohlekraftwerke länger
laufen ja und wir werden auch intensiv
darüber diskutieren wie das mit der
Atomkraft weitergeht und ob man es
zumuten kann dort noch in einen
stressbetrieb zu gehen das sind auch für
diese Koalition harte Diskussion die wir
tun das machen wir aber alles damit es
kein Blackouts gibt damit wir im Winter
Strom haben eine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren und Herr Brantner wenn es
ihnen wirklich darum gegangen wäre heute
mal zu diskutieren wie ist der mit der
Energieversorgung in Deutschland
aussieht ja wir haben anderthalb Stunden
mit dem Chef der Bundesnetzagentur im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
gesprochen anschließend war er eine
Stunde im Wirtschaftsausschuss wo waren
Sie denn wo waren denn ihre Fragen ich
ging es doch gar nicht um die Thematik
ihm ist es doch in keiner Sekunde darum
gegangen wie die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland ist ihnen geht es hier um
ihre Show abzuziehen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das müssen
Sie aber wissen ja
veröffentlichen ja ihre Videos immer so
schön bei Youtube dann soll die Youtube
erlauben mal gucken was überhaupt nicht
neidisch zu was sie da machen ich kann
ihn nur eins sagen liebe Youtube
Gemeinde keine relevanten Fragen der AFD
im Ausschuss für Wirtschaft und Energie
zu diesem Thema das gab es nicht die war
nicht vorhanden und deswegen ist das
hier alles schon was sie abschließen
und ich sage Ihnen auch noch was ich
habe ihn ja gerade dargelegt was wir
alles zum Stand heute schon machen als
Bundesregierung und als sie tragende
Fraktion darüber hinaus haben wir aber
noch ganz viel in der Pipeline wir
werden diese Woche hier hier in der
Ideen Pipeline die ist bei ihnen ja leer
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben eine Idee und konzep online da
ist bei Ihnen nur heiße Luft drin der
Brantner
und wir haben und wir haben und wir
haben hier wirklich einiges noch auf der
Pipeline in der Pipeline ich sage Ihnen
nochmal was wir diese Woche machen
werden wir werden nämlich das Energie
2.0 das energiesicherungsgesetz 3.0 auf
den Weg bringen indem wir Biogas anheben
indem wir Windkraft anheben indem wir
paar PV anheben Photovoltaik indem wir
die beschlagplanung beschleunigen indem
wir die Leitungen besser nutzbar machen
all das kommt noch in diesem Jahr kommt
zeitnah um die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland sicherzustellen die Menschen
in diesem Land können sich auf diese
Koalition verlassen in diesem Sinne
alles Gute und Glück auf
[Applaus]
nächste Redner ist der Kollege Andreas
Jugend cdu/csu-fraktion und erster
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Unionsfraktion
ja Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu der Frage dieser aktuellen
Stunde drohen im Winter
Blackouts ist die Versorgung gesichert
die Bundesregierung einen zweiten
Stresstest in Auftrag gegeben bei den
Übertragungsnetzbetreibern also bei
denen die sich nicht so sehr mit Politik
beschäftigen sondern mit Physik
und die Übertragungsnetzbetreiber sind
zu zwei sehr klaren Ergebnissen gekommen
erstes Ergebnis in diesem Winter droht
nach wie vor das Risiko von Blackouts
und es droht unter ungünstigen anderen
auch des Risiko eines Energie Notstandes
eindeutig aufgeschrieben in diesem
Stresstest
und sie haben zweitens eine Empfehlung
abgegeben die sie als dringende
Empfehlung formulierte
unmissverständlich deshalb gilt es jetzt
in der Krise alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung zu nutzen um einen
solchen Notstand abzuwenden wir fordern
Sie auf die Bundesregierung handeln sie
so wie ihre Experten das Fördern tun sie
alles nutzen Sie alle Möglichkeiten um
eine solche Notlage abzuwenden sie hätte
unabsehbare Konsequenzen und gestern
haben wir den Minister gehört und hat
mitgeteilt des Szenario hat sich
zugespitzt gegenüber dem Stresstest
gegen die die Bundesregierung jetzt
davon aus dass die Situation in
Frankreich gravierender sei als zuvor
angenommen und die Lage sich damit noch
mehr zugespitzt deshalb tun sie alles wo
sie etwas machen haben Sie unsere
Unterstützung das will ich am konkreten
Beispiel machen wir fordern seit Monaten
räumen Sie den Deckel bei der Bio
Energie absetzen sie sich einseitig auf
die Kohle sondern Ebenen sie gerade in
dieser nachhaltigen Form der
Energieerzeugung den Weg und jetzt wird
es gemacht wir haben in den letzten
Wochen ihren Entwurf angeguckt da war
eine Änderung drin ein Deckel sollte weg
aber es sollte der Deckel im
Baugesetzbuch bleiben der sollte
unberührt bleiben ich habe hier an
diesem Pult angekündigt wir werden einen
Antrag einbringen wir werden darauf
dringen dass der Weg kommt sie haben
diese Initiative jetzt aufgegriffen im
Ausschuss haben wir gemeinsam heute früh
den Weg bereitet wir haben dem
zugestimmt der Deckel im Baugesetzbuch
kommt weg das ist ein richtiger ein
wichtiger Schritt
er kommt zu spät in den
Schlussfolgerungen zum Stresstest
schreiben Sie Bioenergie würde im
nächsten Winter mehr zur Verfügung
stehen das hätte früher gemacht werden
können wir unseren Antrag im Sommer
bereits beschlossen hätten aber jetzt
ein richtiger Schritt zweitens
Kernenergie das steht in diesem
Stresstest nutzen Sie alle Möglichkeiten
der Energieerzeugung der steht nicht
lassen sie zwei Kernkraftwerke am Netz
entscheiden Sie das dritte an und
deshalb bitten wir Sie dass auf
Grundlage der Analyse von Robert Habeck
von gestern die Lage hat sich zugespitzt
es ist noch ernster als vor Wochenfrist
gedacht dass tatsächlich alle
Möglichkeiten genutzt werden und das
auch bei der Kernenergie nicht sagt
deutlich es bleibt bei den
grundsatzbeschlüssen Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie genauso wie Ausstieg aus der
Kohle das ist unsere Haltung das ist
unser Beschluss aber jetzt in der Krise
befristet müssen die Möglichkeiten hier
und da genutzt werden und deshalb dürfen
nicht sichere Kernkraftwerke zum
Jahresende in dem Winter wo beiden
Experten sagen der droht eine Notlagen
abgeschaltet werden treffen Sie hier die
notwendigen Entscheidungen jetzt ist
noch Zeit
und jedes bei der Kohle ist heute noch
mal bestätigt worden da sind Sie ja seit
längerem dran
das lediglich zwei
Steinkohlekraftwerke am Netz sind acht
Monate nach dem 24 Februar 2 und warum
wir die Regeln die sie dazu gemacht
haben so kompliziert sind teilweise
widersprüchlich weil sie keine
Verlässlichkeit für die Betreiber
mitbringen auch hier gilt der
Grundsatzbeschluss geht zum Klimaschutz
aber in der Krise muss was nützen man
muss es besser machen als sie es bisher
tun sonst wird das was sie machen wollen
hier nicht zum Erfolg führen auch da
sind Entscheidungen jetzt notwendig
letzte Bemerkung zu gastumlage die hat
uns heute früh beschäftigt im Ausschuss
wir haben im Bundestag ihre diskutiert
in der letzten Woche wir haben einen
Antrag gestellt Aufhebung der Gasanlage
der wurde von den ampelfraktionen
abgelehnt seitdem gibt es aber eine
Entwicklung und alle ampelparteien
erklären jetzt die gasumlage soll nicht
kommen das haben wir heute früh im
Ausschuss beantragt Aufhebung der
gasumlage die Ampel Fraktionen haben
aber geschlossen dagegen gestimmt jetzt
gilt es aber Farbe zu bekennen wir
bringen das diese Woche noch mal in den
Bundestag wer die ich sage nicht will
der muss sie aufheben die ist ja
beschlossen die kommt in drei Tagen
sonst kommt in wenigen Tagen eine
gasumlage die keiner will jetzt haben
sie es noch in der Hand sie sind
gefordert jetzt die Reißleine zu ziehen
die Menschen erwarten hier ist Klarheit
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Kollege jung ja Andreas Jung
war das für die CDU CSU-Fraktion die
Ampelkoalition hat sich ja trotzdem
nächtlicher Verhandlungen in der
vergangenen Nacht noch nicht auf ein
sofortiges aus für die gasumlage ab
Oktober verständigt da geht es ja vor
allem um die
ersatzfinanzierung für die
angeschlagenen gasimporteure die ja noch
gefunden werden muss für die gasumlage
die dann eben nicht starten sollen jedem
Gewissen ausmachen und sich fragen ob
sie sich morgens noch in den Spiegel
schauen können wenn sie hier als
Sprachrohr der russischen Propaganda
auftreten
das tun sie wiederholt sie waren letztes
Jahr in Moskau auf einer Konferenz wo
sie die Abschaffung der Sanktionen
gefordert haben und sie stellen hier
spurbelige Vermutung und den Raum zu
nordstreams 2 zu den Anschlägen die
passiert sind offensichtlich sie sind
derjenige der Wladimir Putin hier im
Deutschen Bundestag vertritt das werden
wir deutlich aussprechen und sie dabei
auch einen Namen nennen
die Lage ist viel zu ernst und mit einer
solchen Folklore sich
länger auseinanderzusetzen
die Lage ist so dass die Bundesregierung
nach dem russischen Beginn des
Angriffskrieges in der Ukraine am 24
Februar
drastische und umfassende Maßnahmen in
die Wege geleitet hat wir haben jetzt
Ende September wir sind mit vollen
gasspeichern jetzt hier das ist ein
großer Erfolg dieser Bundesregierung
wir haben gestern die Ankündigung von
Robert Habeck gehört das will ich
zugestehen das fällt uns Grünen gar
nicht einfach dass auch die Notreserve
von zwei Atomkraftwerken genutzt werden
soll für den kommenden Winter damit wir
gut durch diesen Winter kommen und auch
entsprechend psychologisch Signale auf
den Markt ausrichten
und wir haben auch Dank zu sagen der
Industrie auch den Haushalten die beim
Thema Energieeinsparung angepackt haben
leider auch das muss man auch bitte
sagen bei den hohen Preisen die wir
vorzufinden hatten in den letzten
Monaten ausgelöst durch diesen
Angriffskrieg auch zum Teil durch
produktionsstilligungen und einfach ein
Abbau der Produktion in vielen Betrieben
wir handeln jetzt indem wir
Wirtschaftshilfen auf den Weg bringen
ich gehe davon aus dass die
Bundesregierung auch in den nächsten
Stunden zu einer Einigung kommt wie bei
beim Thema gaspreisdeckel vorankommen
und auch eine strompreisbremse ist nicht
nur im Gespräch sondern wird zeitnah
umgesetzt werden
aber es gehört auch zur Wahrheit all
diejenigen und ich habe halt auch in der
Fragestunde aufmerksam zugehört die
jetzt nur Negatives Szenarien in den
Raum stellen und die immer nur die
Katastrophe bei beschwören das ist keine
verantwortliche Oppositionsarbeit
wir müssen jetzt auch dafür sorgen die
Maßnahmen die wir auf dem Weg gebracht
haben als Stabilisierung der Märkte für
die Unternehmen für die Verbraucher auch
den Menschen zu erklären und natürlich
müssen wir bereit sein weil wir das
Szenario des kommenden Winters nicht
kennen wir können nicht lügen und sagen
wir wissen wie alles sein wird das
wissen wir nicht aber wir können sagen
dass wir alles getan haben bis zum
jetzigen Tag um die extremsten Szenarien
zu vermeiden dass es Wahrheit und auch
Wahrheit gehört in der Politik mal
gesagt
und
persönlich neige ich nicht zu
Pessimismus ich sage es Ihnen ganz
deutlich wir werden jetzt auch sinkende
Preise in aller Voraussicht nach sehen
im Bereich Gas und auch im Bereich Strom
durch die Maßnahmen der Bundesregierung
konstruktiv unterstützt von der Union in
vielen Bereichen das will ich auch
ausdrücklich loben aber wir sehen
einfach auch durch die Herausforderungen
die wir jetzt angenommen haben das
Füllen der Gasspeicher dass wir
plötzlich in der Lage sind auch wieder
Gas auszuspeichern das heißt auf den
Markt wieder etwas mehr Stabilität
zuzuführen wir sprechen intensiv mit
unseren europäischen Partnern ihre
Politik von der AFD ist ja immer
isoliert zu handeln wir handeln im
europäischen Verbund und deswegen lösen
wir die Krise denn wir handeln würden
wie sie wäre unsere Volkswirtschaft
längst ruiniert und dass sie als Büttel
Russland sie auftreten ist ohne dies
eine Schande für dieses Parlament das
will ich mal so deutlich auch sagen
das heißt die Szenarien im Strombereich
sind wir handeln wir schaffen Sicherheit
wir helfen in entsprechenden
Haushaltsmitteln wenn es nach uns geht
in der grünen Fraktion dann ist es auch
die Zeit die finanziellen Freiräume zu
nutzen das ist jetzt nicht Zeit für die
schwäbische Hausfrau muss man so
deutlich zu sagen im Bereich der
Haushaltspolitik oder den Hausmann ich
wurde gerade böse angeschaut aus meiner
Fraktion zu Recht
aber der Punkt ist am Ende das
verantwortlich sie können ja lachen uns
spotten wie Sie wollen aber das Problem
ist dass ihnen ja außer Panikmache und
Angst mache und dann auch so dieses
Verhalten von infrarotfall also sie
stellen sich hier hin und stellen in
Frage wer denn den Anschlag auf
Nordstemmen 2 und tun so als wären wir
das selber gewesen ich meine was ist
denn das für ein Handel ihrer Fraktion
sie tun so als wären sie eine nationale
Opposition dabei sind sie letztlich wenn
man mal ihre Sprache benimmt der Feind
des deutschen Volkes das wäre sozusagen
ihre Sprache die man benutzen müsste
also das ist ja intellektuell alles gar
nicht mehr zu fassen was ihr Vorbringen
entscheidend ist jetzt dass wir hier
entschlossen handeln und das in der
schwierigen Zeit aber dass wir den
Leuten auch nicht erzählen dass alles
automatisch gut wird es wird jetzt erst
eine schwere Zeit kommen bevor es besser
wird wir helfen gemeinsam wir sind
solidarisch und wir helfen vor allem den
schwächsten dass sie Vorankommen vielen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege janicek
bis zur Redner ist der Kollege Ralf
lenkert Fraktion DIE LINKE
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Kolleginnen
und Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ja viele haben Angst vor dem
kundenwinder und da gibt es zwei sorgen
die erste Sorge ist gibt es Strom und
die zweite Sorge ist kann ich ihn mir
leisten und auf beide Fragen muss die
Bundesregierung muss die Koalition eine
Antwort geben
jetzt komme ich zur Sicherheit dass die
Stromversorgung gefährdet ist hätte ich
mir im Frühjahr nicht träumen lassen
aber seitdem in Frankreich ein
Atomkraftwerk nach dem anderen havariert
ein Atomkraftwerk nach dem anderen
teilweise zehn Jahre jünger als die
deutschen Atomkraftwerke nicht mehr
funktionieren kann macht fängt man an
sich Sorgen zu machen
das ist ein Problem und deswegen hat man
in Deutschland
Kohlekraftwerke wieder freigegeben aber
warum sind die noch nicht am Markt und
warum haben wir überhaupt noch Probleme
und da möchte ich mal ganz einfach sagen
der Stresstest der immer erwähnt wird
ist richtig und da hätte ich geglaubt
dass wir ein Problem haben wenn kein
Wind weht oder wenig Wind da ist und
gerade viel Strom benötigt wird da haben
wir kein Problem wir haben ein Problem
in Deutschland wenn viel Wind im Norden
weht und im Süden viel Strom gebraucht
wird und das müssen wir mal jemand
erklären als wenn im Knochen kein Wind
weht und im Süden viel Strom verbraucht
wird haben wir kein Problem aber wenn im
Norden viel Wind weht wie hängt das
zusammen
das ist das Marktdesign was man hat ihr
kommt durch die Liberalisierung und das
hat folgenschwachsinn wenn ein
Unternehmen ein Großhändler im Süden den
billigen Windstrom im Norden kaufen will
weil er auch da ist dann kriegt er ihn
und wenn die Stromleitung aber zu klein
sind um den Strom durchzulassen dann
kriegt er den Strom trotzdem zu diesen
Preis das Windräder werden aber
stillgelegt und gleichzeitig werden in
Süddeutschland weil ja die Windräder
eigentlich liefern sollten eventuell
teure Gaskraftwerke runtergefahren und
um dann den Strombedarf zu decken werden
noch teurer ritis patchkraftwerke also
ältere Gaskraftwerke hochgefahren ja
diesen Schwachsinn muss man doch beenden
wenigstens in dieser Situation sollten
Sie sich von diesen irrenmarkt Gedanken
trennen
natürlich muss man auch die
Stromversorgung dadurch sichern dass man
mehr Strom bereitstellt und das hat ja
die Union schon gesagt den biogasdeckel
hätten wir schon im Frühsommer aufheben
können 10% unserer Stromversorgung
könnten wir mit zusätzlichen Biogas
bereitstellen wenn denn der Decke
aufgehoben wird wenn den entsprechend
gehandelt wird das ist jetzt im
Parlament es ist leider sehr spät aber
hoffentlich nicht zu spät und natürlich
gibt es weitere Möglichkeiten
mittelfristig und langfristig Grip
bringen wir unsere Sicherheit der
Energieversorgung am besten dadurch hin
dass wir die fossilen Rohstoffe beenden
und wenn wir kein fossiles Gas brauchen
dann ist es auch egal welche Leitung wie
läuft das ist der Fakt und deswegen
haben die Linken Landesregierung mit
Beteiligung 100 milliardenprogramm
gefordert für zum einen Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien zum Ausbau von
speichern und zum sichern
das Lebens der Menschen damit sie die
Energie bezahlen können auch mit kleine
und mittlere Firmen überleben über den
Winter kommen dieses Paket könnten wir
hier verabschieden aber da sage ich ganz
offen
wenn es um die Menschen geht sind ihnen
100 Milliarden zu teuer wenn es um
Rüstung geht sieht es anders aus
und jetzt
und jetzt möchte ich noch mal einen
weiteren Punkt benennen die Spekulation
ist ein riesiges Problem
binstrom kostet in der Erzeugung ca 5
Cent in Deutschland Solarstrom circa 6
Cent Kohlestrom ist zwischen 4 und 18 zu
haben
Strompreis
die Spanne dazwischen sind
Spekulationsgewinne neben den Abgaben
und da gibt es in den Fall so dass
einige Unternehmen im ersten Quartal
diesen Jahres mehr Gewinn gemacht haben
als im gesamten letzten Quartal da kann
die FDP natürlich keine übergewinne
erkennen logischerweise wahrscheinlich
brauchen sie eine Brille
aber diese übergewinne müssen kassiert
werden die müssen kassiert werden und
das ist zwingend erforderlich und
deswegen fordert DIE LINKE die
Spekulation zu beenden und das kann man
am besten den an einem preisdeckel
einführt ein preisdeckel jetzt sofort
und selbst der Preisträger wird nicht
reichen damit Bürgerinnen und Bürger bei
einer sicheren Energieversorgung auch
die Energie bezahlen können deswegen
fordern wir ein mindergeld genannt von
monatlich 125 Euro für jeden Haushalt
plus 50 Euro für jede Person im Haushalt
über eins hinausgehen damit die Energie
bezahlbar ist wir fordern Strom und
gasperren zu verbieten und ich kann es
nur wiederholen wir fordern ein
energiepreisdeckel einen preisdeckel auf
Heizenergie auf Strom und Gas auch für
unsere kleine mittleren Unternehmen
damit die weiter produzieren können die
Arbeitsplätze halten bleiben und damit
unsere Gesellschaft gesichert ist so
gewinnt man Sicherheit und nicht mit
solchen billigen Anträgen wie von der
AFD vielen Dank
so weit Ralf lenkert für die
Linksfraktion der Sprecher für Energie
Klimaschutz und Umweltpolitik direkt auf
ihn antworten würden und der
energiepolitische Sprecher der Liberalen
hier im Bundestag Michael Kruse
herr Präsident meine lieben Kolleginnen
und Kollegen also zunächst mal ist das
Thema heute ja recht kurzfristig
eingetrudeltes lautet auf Blackout ein
Blick in die Tageszeitung und aktuellen
Meldungen lässt nur eines zu der einzige
Blackout den ich heute erkennen kann ist
der das in ihrer Geschäftsstelle schon
wieder Räume durchsucht werden müssen
weil sie es nicht mal schaffen ihre
eigenen Parteifinanzen zuordnen meine
sehr geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Blackout hat also bei ihren Finanzen
gegeben im deutschen Strommarkt nicht
denn wir sorgen dafür dass es auch im
nächsten Winter genügend Strom geben
wird das einzige worüber ich mich
wirklich freue ist dass die Berliner
Staatsanwaltschaft jetzt ganz
entschlossen gegen clankriminalität
vorgeht offensichtlich
wir tun seit Beginn dieses russischen
Angriffskrieges sehen sie wieder nicht
geschafft haben zu erwähnen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
afd-fraktion aber gleich haben sie ja
noch mal eine Gelegenheit seit Beginn
dieses Angriffskrieges tut die Ampel
alles dafür dass wir unsere Energie
Souveränität wieder zurück erlangen es
gibt das energiesicherungsgesetz in
diesem Land von 1975 das jahrzehntelang
nicht angepasst worden ist jetzt in
dieser Woche haben wir die dritte
Novelle innerhalb dieses Jahres dazu
verabschiedet mit der ersten haben wir
sichergestellt dass die Deutschen
Gasspeicher zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt so
voll sind wie noch nie zu diesem
Zeitpunkt wir sorgen für
energiesouveränität in Deutschland meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
er ist aber ganz spannend was wir in
dieser Woche so alles machen wir haben
noch mehr Tempo beim Thema erneuerbare
Energien vereinbart wir haben den LNG
Turbo noch beschleunigt wir sorgen für
einen weiteren Standort beim Thema LNG
und ja wir sorgen auch für
Planungssicherheit für die
Kohlekraftwerke die bis 2024 ans Netz
zurückkehren können und das heute auch
schon wissen jetzt ja ganz spannend wenn
Sie das eigentlich doch immer fordern
dass wir genau das tun sollen Liebe AFD
wie kommt es dass sie es wieder nicht
geschafft haben diesen Anträgen auch
zuzustimmen ich will es ihnen sagen sie
haben überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran
den Blackout in diesem Land zu
verhindern wer ihnen auf Social Media
folgt weiß sie sehnen ihn ja geradezu
herbei wir werden ihnen diesen Gefallen
nicht tun weil uns die Menschen und
Unternehmen in diesem Land am Herzen
liegen und deswegen werden wir dafür
sorgen dass es keinen Blackout gibt im
kommenden Winter
und ja die Koalition hat Beachtliches
geleistet ich möchte auch mal Lob für
die koalitionspartnerinnen und
Koalitionspartner aussprechen es ist für
uns wesentlich leichter zu formulieren
dass die Kernkraftwerke länger laufen
müssen es gab dazu einen Stresstest und
auch dieser Stresstest er war ja sehr
wichtig genau um zu erkennen wo denn zum
Beispiel im Winter noch Potenziale
gehoben werden müssen um zu erkennen wo
wir redest Patch Bedarf haben der noch
kontrahiert werden muss und es ist nicht
leicht für eine Partei die sich im Kern
auf das Ende der Kernenergie gegründet
hat für diese Partei für ein Minister
selbst dieser Partei zu erkennen dass es
offensichtlich notwendig sein könnte die
Kernkraftwerke in diesem Land länger
laufen zu lassen aber wenn Herr Harbeck
in der Lage ist das zu erkennen obwohl
er ein ganz anderes politisches Ziel in
seinem ganzen Leben immer verfolgt hat
dann müsste es ihnen doch auch möglich
sein zu erkennen dass sie auf dem
falschen politischen aussehen dass sie
nicht fordern müssen dass die Pipelines
Richtung Russland repariert werden
müssen weil das sowieso kein Gas mehr
durchfließt sondern dass wir stattdessen
dafür sorgen müssen dass die Pipelines
über die Tag für Tag sehr viel Gas nach
Deutschland kommen nämlich aus
Frankreich neuerdings nämlich aus
Norwegen dass diese Pipelines geschützt
werden und zwar vor all denjenigen die
sich das wünschen was sie eigentlich
herbeiwünschen nämlich ein Blackout und
Katastrophen in diesem Land meine sehr
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir handeln wir sorgen dafür dass
energiesouveränität in diesem Land
zurückkommt und wir sorgen dafür dass
die Preise gesenkt werden wir werden
noch heute eine sonderausschusssitzung
im Ausschuss für Klima und Energie
durchführen um dafür zu sorgen dass die
Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer für Gas nicht
nur für das Gas gilt sondern dass sie
auch für die Fernwärme gilt in diesem
Monat in diesem Tagen erreichen die
deutschen Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer die energiepreispauschale
die genau damit dafür hilft damit
umzugehen dass Energiepreise in den
nächsten Monaten steigen wir haben als
FDP in der Koalition durchgesetzt dass
die kalte Progression abgebaut wird zwei
große Koalitionen hintereinander waren
dazu nicht in der Lage und last but not
least sorgen wir dafür dass der
Grundbedarf an Energie auch weiterhin
für jeden in diesem Land leistbar ist
herzlichen Dank vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Kruse
und damit kommen wir zu der Partei
wieder die diese aktuelle Stunde hier
verlangt hat in Rico coming von der
afd-fraktion ist der nächste Redner
sehr geehrter Präsident meine Damen und
Herren Kollegen Liebe Kollege gremmels
sie haben ja eine mangelnde Anwesenheit
der AFD heute im Wirtschaftsausschuss
angesprochen ich kann ihnen ich muss das
hier mal richtig stellen und darf sagen
dass die AFD fast vollständig da war ich
meine dass die SPD mit
wirtschaftspolitischer Blindheit
geschlagen ist das wissen wir ja alle
dass sich das auch auf ihr Augenlicht
auswirkt ist doch sehr bedauerlich
ich war ich war heute zusammen mit
einigen anderen wirtschaftspolitikern
beim Nordic Talk der IHK Nord und dort
wurde ein Papier zu den Auswirkungen der
Energiekrise ausgeteilt Frau Nestle sie
waren ja auch da ich fand die Beiträge
von der AFD und auch von der CDU das
muss ich ehrlich sagen sehr vernünftig
sehr hilfreich Frau Nestle vielleicht
übergeben Sie das Papier nachher mal
Herrn Kellner damit das
Wirtschaftsministerium auch weiß wie
vernünftige mittelstands- und
handwerkspolitik gemacht wird
meine Damen und Herren die Energie und
Wirtschaftspolitik der Bundesregierung
für Deutschland den Mittelstand und das
Handwerk in einer der schwersten
ökonomischen Krisen seit dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges und das verantworten
Sie meine Damen und Herren Kollegen von
der Bundesregierung
Industrieunternehmen wandern ab
Mittelständler und Handwerker gehen
schadenweise pleite und die Bürger
wissen nicht mehr wovon Sie Ihre Heizung
bezahlen sollen seit Februar diesen
Jahres ist die energieintensive
Produktion um knapp sieben Prozent wegen
der explodierenden Preise regelrecht
eingebrochen der deutliche Rückgang des
Stromverbrauchs allein von Mai auf Juni
um fünf Terawattstunden liegt aber nicht
an sparsamen Bürgern sondern liegt an
stillstehenden Fließbändern und man
sieht es auch schon in den Läden so
Lehrer Regale wie es die heute gibt gab
es seit DDR-Zeiten nicht mehr
Deutschland war schon in den letzten
Jahren dank der katastrophalen
Energiewende eines der teuersten
energieländer der Welt zu Lasten unser
Standort Attraktivität ein Pfund mit dem
wir jedoch bis heute noch wuchern
konnten war die relative politische
rechtliche und soziale Stabilität des
Standorts aber auch diese ist jetzt
nicht nur gefährdet sie ist Schnee von
gestern abgesehen von diesen von ihrem
Maßnahmen Chaos übergewinnsteuer ja oder
nein das Umlage ja jetzt wieder nein
oder vielleicht doch wir wissen es nicht
mit der Zerstörung der nordstream zwei
Pipelines hat sich die Lage fundamental
zu Schlechten verändert und die
Bundesregierung hat nicht einen Hauch
eines Plans
die Sicherheit des Stromnetzes meine
Damen und Herren in Deutschland steht
nicht dass seit heute auf der Kippe die
Energiewende mit der Abkehr von
grundlastfähigen Energieträgern
erfordert inzwischen so viele Eingriffe
in das Stromnetz wie nie zuvor
stromexperten sind sich einig dass ich
nicht die Frage stellt ob es einen
Blackout gibt sondern wann er kommt die
vorgeblich vollen Gas speichern auf die
sie als Bundesregierung ja immer so
stolz verweisen sie reichen nur dann für
den Winter wenn es Nachschub gibt so
reicht das Gast wurde heute schon
angesprochen vielleicht für acht bis
zehn höchstens zwölf Wochen das bringt
uns bis Anfang Dezember vielleicht bis
Weihnachten und dann liebe
Bundesregierung allein der Stromanteil
von Gass im Jahr 2021 lag bei gut zehn
Prozent wenn der jetzt auch noch
wegfällt potenziert sich das Blackout
Risiko die Beschwichtigung der
Bundesregierung ist denn der Fragestunde
sind durchsichtig und nützen vor allem
niemanden ebenso wenig wie das wie die
arroganten und ausweichenden Antworten
von Frau Dr Brandner auf die Nachfragen
der AFD meine Damen und Herren ein
Blackout in Deutschland würde
wirtschaftliche Verwerfungen
Größenordnungen nach sich ziehen die
niemand heute absehen kann von den
gesellschaftlichen will ich gar nicht
reden es gilt den Blackout jetzt
unbedingt zu vermeiden und das heißt
nicht zwei sondern alle drei aktiven
Kernkraftwerke müssen am Netz bleiben
und so viel andere wie möglich wieder
hochgefahren werden
die wieder in Betriebnahme der
stillgelegten Kohlekraftwerke muss jetzt
und unbürokratisch eingeleitet werden
zur Vermeidung eines Blackouts brauchen
wir jetzt
grundlastfähigen Strom Sie meine Damen
und Herren von der Bundesregierung sie
haben geschworen Schaden vom deutschen
Volk abzuwenden fangen Sie endlich damit
an danke sehr
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächste Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde ist Nina Scheer die Sprecherin
für Klimaschutz und Energie der
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen mein Kollege
Timon grebbels hat es ja gerade auch
schon bemerkt in Richtung der hier
beantragenden Fraktionen der AFD dass
die Rede offenkundig vorbereitet war
sind sofern bitte ich das tatsächlich
mal unter die Lupe zu nehmen ob hier
Missbrauch stattfindet dieses dieses
Missbrauch stattfindet in der Frage wann
dieses Instrument
gezogen wird von ihrer Seite bei einem
red da kann man vielleicht doch
überlegen okay das ist vielleicht eine
schubladenrede von der Sorte mögen sie
vielleicht ja auch ein paar haben wie
man manchmal glauben mag aber jetzt ist
schon der zweite Redner das ist schon
der zweite Redner der sich hier ans Pult
begibt und wortwörtlich abliest nichts
gegen ablesen das geht ja aber warum ist
die Frage ist wie kann das sein dass in
einer aktuellen Stunde die gerade mal
von der Dreiviertelstunde beauftragt
wurde naja gut also die Botschaft ist
gesetzt ich möchte auch gar nicht mit
ihnen da in Dialog darüber treten das
sollten nur alle wissen dass das
offenkund ein installiertes Manöver ist
was sie hier abhalten und somit ist hier
glaube ich auch alles zugesagt
insofern
zur Sache die sie hier nochmal zum
wiederholten Male aufgeworfen haben und
diese aber natürlich schon im Detail von
Staatssekretärin Brantner beantwortet
wurden das ist auch insofern
auch insofern unwahr dass sie
unterstellen dass dies nicht beantwortet
wurde denn man kann natürlich nicht eine
fachliche Antwort
eine fachliche Antwort mit einer
Erwartungshaltung überfrachten die in
der Zukunft erst zu beantworten ist und
es gibt zukünftige geschehen die mit den
heutigen Kenntnissen schlichtweg nicht
zu beantworten sind ja das kann dass das
liegt nun mal einfach in dem Wesen von
Zukunft man kann aber hier in der
Bundesregierung im Parlament Vorsorge
leisten und die vorsorgeaufgaben die
hier geleistet wurden von der
Bundesregierung und vom Parlament die
sind enorm und die sind genau in auf der
Linie von Versorgungssicherheit von
Daseinsvorsorge vielfach abgesichert
worden wir haben mit dem lng-gesetz
Vorsorge für Diversifizierung geschaffen
wir haben mit einer mehrfachen
Überarbeitung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes Vorsorge
getroffen es sind ersatzkraftwerke in
der Bereitstellung und sind in die
Bereitstellung schon gegangen wir haben
an den liefer- und Transportwegen
Erleichterungen geschaffen damit auch
wirklich die Versorgung der Kraftwerke
auch gewährleistet ist wir haben jetzt
gerade heute im Ausschuss eine weitere
Novelle des energiesicherungsgesetzes
verabschiedet und werden dies in dieser
Woche noch parlamentarisch verabschieden
womit wir mit einem erneuerbaren
Energien Booster all diese Mengen
benennen die wir im Bereich erneuerbare
Energien schon mit bestehenden Anlagen
herausziehen können um damit auch
weitere Mengen Energiemengen liefern zu
können und das müssen sie alles ganz
genau sie haben wir heute morgen im
Ausschuss als Fraktion genauso
teilgenommen wie die anderen Fraktionen
auch es sei denn Sie haben nicht
zugehört da hätten sie das alles ja auch
vernehmen können dass diese Instrumente
alle auf den Weg gebracht wurden und
dass sie auch natürlich wirken werden
wir haben zudem eine schon über 90
Prozent gefüllte
speichersituation mit den gasspeichern
und wir haben in der Tat auch an anderen
Stellen ich möchte noch mal kurz
zitieren aus einem Bericht den wir heute
auch oder bzw von von von Aussagen aus
dem Parlament heraus in Richtung
Bundesregierung und das werden wir auch
gemeinsam mit die Umsetzung bringen was
wir auch in die Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses hineingenommen haben da ist
auch noch mal festgehalten von uns
parlamentarisch festgehalten das
natürlich auch in einer Notfallsituation
die übrigens von der Bundesnetzagentur
die auch schon Frau Brandner ausgerufen
wurde nicht für diesen Winter nun
befürchtet wurde und auch nicht
prognostiziert wird dass sie aber
gleichwohl für den Fall eines Eintritts
als einer solchen Lage auch Vorsorge
leisten dahingehend dass eben nicht ins
Mark der gesellschaftlichen
Handlungsfähigkeit eingegriffen werden
wird sondern dass die Betätigung so
gesellschaftliche Betätigung sowohl im
wirtschaftlichen als auch
gesellschaftlichen Bereich natürlich so
weit wie möglich aufrechterhalten werden
müssen weil wir natürlich wissen dass
nur eine funktionsfähige Gesellschaft
auch in der Lage dazu ist uns
systematisch aus der Krise
herauszuführen und das systematische
herausführen heißt natürlich dass wir
auf Alternativen setzen müssen denn eins
ist klar diese Krise ist eine fossile
energiepreiskrise eine fossile wenn wir
es nicht schaffen schnellstmöglich auf
erneuerbare Energien umzusteigen und
auch systemisch darauf umzusteigen dann
wird es umso schwerer solche Situationen
zu vermeiden in die uns in die wir
manövriert wurden über die Folgewirkung
des russischen Angriffskrieges und noch
ein letztes an den letzten Sekunden die
meiner Redezeit bleiben in der Tat hat
dieser botage die mögliche Sabotage das
gilt es noch zu untersuchen der
nordstream 1 und 2 Pipelines an diesen
Pipelines rein gar nichts mit der
Versorgungssicherheit zu tun das wissen
Sie denn da fließt zurzeit überhaupt
kein Gas durch vielen dank vielen Dank
Frau Kollegin
ess der Kollege Dr Andreas
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
möchte ich betonen dass ich es schade
finde dass sie eigentlich angeraumte
aktuelle Stunde über das Thema Iran
nicht stattfinden kann ich
ich hatte gerade eine herzzerreißende
Nachricht aus dem Wahlkreis eines
deutsch-iranischen Pass die sich an mich
gewandt haben und gesagt haben sie
hoffen auf diese aktuelle Stunde sie
hoffen dass diese Schicksale auch
entsprechend in die Öffentlichkeit
kommen und deswegen und deswegen freue
ich mich auch dass wir das morgen
nachholen aber ich möchte auch betonen
wie wichtig das ist
ein Einsatz zur gasumlage am Anfang
meiner Ausführungen die ampelchaos
gasumlage die murksumlage wird leider
nicht besser und auch in dieser Woche
haben wir eigentlich keine Neuigkeiten
erfahren von einer muss weg
oppositionsansage von Minister Harbeck
zu einer muss
deck-ampelkoalitionsansage jetzt würde
mich eigentlich interessieren bei der
Ampel wer will denn eigentlich diese
gasumlage noch ich weiß es nicht und in
der letzten Woche in der letzten Woche
hat eigentlich sich der Zustand ja
vermehrt dass eigentlich immer mehr auch
Stimmen aus der Ampel für diese
Abschaffung der Umlage waren und jetzt
haben wir heute im Ausschuss nachgefragt
was ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit der
Umlage weil man muss ja wissen wenn
nichts gemacht wird dann zieht der
Paragraph 26 entzig also die Verordnung
dass die Gasanlage am ersten zehnten
kommt und jetzt haben sie auch bei der
aktuellen Stunde Frau Nessel die
Möglichkeit zu sagen was denn eigentlich
jetzt passiert und ob jetzt die
Raucherinnen und Verbraucher ob die
Versorger jetzt am 1.10 die gasumlage
bezahlen einziehen sollen oder nicht wir
brauchen an dieser Stelle Klarheit meine
Damen und Herren und wenn ich jetzt auf
die Frage des Blackouts komme dann
möchte ich schon sagen die AFD führt
hier Ängste und das macht die Situation
im Moment ja nicht besser wir haben eine
wir haben eine gute eine verlässliche
Infrastruktur wenn es darum geht die
Stromversorgung aber auch die
Gasversorgung zu gewährleisten aber wir
sind natürlich anfällig und das zeigen
auch die Anschläge auf Nord Stream das
ist eine neue Eskalationsstufe aber ich
warne auch davor jetzt schon zu
spekulieren wer dahinter steckt diese
diese Spekulationen verbieten sich und
letzten Endes letzten Endes möchte ich
schon auch betonen das nur dass nur weil
in der Vergangenheit die Versorgung
verlässlich war das nichts heißt das
sind dass es in Zukunft zu sein muss und
insofern waren wir
seit März vor Engpässen die natürlich im
schlimmsten Fall auch zu einem Blackout
führen könnten und wir sagen seit März
dass wir ein befristeten Weiterbetrieb
der AKWs wollen und wenn ich mir da die
Ausführungen noch vom März von den
Ministerien anschaue dann sind die ja
das Papier nicht wert wo sie drauf
stehen damals hieß es noch es geht nicht
übrigens in der letzten Woche noch vor
fünf Tagen hat die
Bundesumweltministerin einen weiteren
Betrieb abgelehnt sie hat gesagt zu
teuer zu risikoreich und es kann doch
nur ampelchaos sein wenn gestern die der
Weiterbetrieb zumindest im Süden
entsprechend verkündet wird und übrigens
sagt der Stresstest der Stresstest der
Netzbetreiber sagt eben ganz klar dass
wir schwarzstartfähige dass wir
grundlastfähige Kapazitäten brauchen
gerade im Winter und deswegen ist die
Entscheidung für die Kraftwerke im Süden
richtig aber es stellt sich doch
natürlich die Frage warum das Kraftwerk
in Lingen im Emsland nicht weiter
betrieben werden soll auch im Norden
braucht man natürlich verlässliche
gesicherte le und wenn Herr janicek sagt
es wird alles gemacht dann wird eben
nicht alles gemacht um die
Versorgungssicherheit entsprechend zu
gewährleisten und daran messen wir sie
der Winter 2023 2024 wird auch schwierig
heute hat der Präsident der
Bundesnetzagentur der Klaus Müller
gesagt dass der Winter im nächsten Jahr
genauso schwierig wird wenn ich
schwieriger als der im letzten Jahr und
deswegen fordern wir Sie auf schaffen
sie jetzt schon Verlässlichkeit für die
Kraftwerke dass sie auch bis 24
entsprechend am Netz bleiben können und
entsprechend produzieren können für die
Versorgungssicherheit das geht natürlich
auch für die Kohlekraft es ist so dass
erst zwei Kraftwerke wieder ans Netz
gekommen sind das liegt an der
Brennstoff Bevorratung das liegt auch an
der Befristung des Betriebs des 30.04.23
wir sehen einige wichtige Punkte die aus
unserer Sicht umgesetzt wurden die wir
gefordert haben bei den Erneuerbaren bei
der Biomasse bei PV bei Energieeffizienz
und es ist letzten Endes ja so dass wir
hoffen dass das beste kommt also immer
das Beste hoffen aber natürlich der
schlimmste auf das Schlimmste
vorbereitet sein müssen und deswegen
noch mal das der den Appellativ machen
sie wirklich alles was zur Verfügung
steht um die Kapazitäten die wir haben
ans Netz zu bringen um die Potenziale
bei Energieeffizienz bei den
Erneuerbaren entsprechend zu nutzen und
dann hätten sie uns auch an ihrer Seite
aber leider machen sie das noch nicht
und insofern bitten wir da unsere
Vorschläge entsprechend auch zur
Kenntnis zu nehmen und umzusetzen dann
haben wir auch mehr Sicherheit für die
Versorgung im nächsten und im
übernächsten Winter herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Andreas Lenz war das hier in
der Aktuellen Stunde zu den möglichen
Auswirkungen eines Blackouts dazu
spricht nun Ingrid Nestle die Sprecherin
für Klimaschutz und Energie der grünen
Fraktion hier im Bundestag
Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Regierung nimmt die
Situation auf den Energiemärkten bei der
Energieversorgung sehr ernst
und auch deshalb ist es so schändlich
dass sie von der AFD dieses Thema das so
wichtig ist für die Menschen im Land für
die Versorgungssicherheit aber auch für
die Preise dass sie dieses Thema für
gezielt für Desinformationen nutzen
es grenzt das grenzt tatsächlich schon
ein bisschen an hohen dass sie dieses
Thema jetzt heute hier in einer
aktuellen Stunde hochziehen
denn es gibt drei es gibt drei Krisen
die gerade gleichzeitig im
Energiebereich Europa so und wir
verlassen den Bundestag an dieser Stelle
für ein paar Minuten den
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen und EU-Außenbeauftragte Joseph
Borrell wollen sich in Brüssel auch zu
den Lex an den nordstream Pipelines
äußernde wollen wir natürlich zuhören
mit Gewalt zu ändern die Mobilisierung
und die Drohungen durch Putin
sind weitere Schritte auf dem
eskalationsweg wir akzeptieren diese
scheinreferenten Nichte oder irgendeine
Form der Annexion in der Ukraine und wir
sind entschlossen dafür zu sorgen dass
der Creme für diese weitere Eskalation
bezahlt
heute schlagen wir gemeinsam ein neues
Paket mit harten Sanktionen gegen
Russland vor
der erste Teil betrifft die Auflistung
von Personen und Organisationen
das wird der Hohe Vertreter gleich
vorstellen ich möchte mich jetzt auch
den zweiten Teil der Sanktionen
konzentrieren und den Handel weiter zu
beschränken damit isolieren wir die
russische Wirtschaft noch weiter und
versetzen hier einen Schlag wir schlagen
der umfassende neue einfuhrverbote für
russische Produkte vor das wird die
russischen Produkte vom europäischen
Markt fernhalten
was weitere sieben Milliarden Euro
weniger an Einnahmen bedeutet wir
schlagen außerdem vor die Liste der
Produkte auszudehnen die nicht mehr nach
Russland ausgeführt werden können
das Ziel ist es hier
der Kriegsmaschine des Cremes
Schlüsseltechnologien zu entziehen dazu
gehören zum Beispiel weitere
luftverkehrsgüter oder elektronische
Komponente oder spezifische chemische
Stoffe
diese neuen ausfuhrverbote werden weiter
die wirtschaftliche Grundlage Russlands
und die modernisierungskraft des Landes
schwächenal außerdem werden wir weitere
Verbote vorschlagen für die Erbringung
europäischer Dienstleistungen gegenüber
Russland und ein Verbot für
eu-staatsangehörige in Leitungsgremien
russischer Staatsbetriebe zu sitzen
Russland darf nicht Tiere meine
Gesellschaft noch viel tiefer in der
Patsche
und zu dieser
zu dieser Kampagne der Desinformation
passt was sie gerade abgezogen haben sie
verweisen auf das Papier der DHK das
gerade eben verteilt worden ist und tun
so und tun so als würde sie ihre
Position treffen Sie versuchen eine eine
ernste eine ehrliche eine gute eine
wichtige Organisation zu vereinnahmen
für ihre Ziele und ich werde nur einen
Punkt rausgreifen hier steht der Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien er muss viel
schneller kommen hier steht die
Windkraftanlagen werden viel zu oft
abgeschaltet erst heute im Ausschuss
erst heute im Ausschuss haben sie sich
beklagt weil wir genau das ändern weil
wir genau die Forderung der DHK umsetzen
und sie haben dagegen gesprochen sie
haben uns dafür kritisiert weil sie eben
nicht hinter diesen Forderungen stehen
ich habe so ein und sie haben auch schon
manchmal hier ganz schön rumgebrüllt und
ja es geht vor Flagge zu zeigen es geht
Flagge zu zeigen wenn Sie dieses Land
mit Desinformationen überziehen weil wir
in einer wirklich ernsten Lage sind und
deswegen haben wir diese Regierung und
ja wir ziehen alle Register wir haben
das größte Paket zum Auto erneuerbaren
Energien aller Zeiten aufgelegt auch
diese Woche kommt noch mehr Windstrom
dazu es kommt noch mehr Biomasse Strom
dazu mehr Solarstrom dazu alles wenn
energiesicherungsgesetz wir haben die
Kohlekraftwerke wieder eine Mark
gebracht wir haben die LNG Terminals
reingebracht wir haben noch mal jetzt
nachgeschärft bei den Kohlekraftwerken
selbst die Atomkraftwerke sie haben die
versorgungssicherheitsstrom angesprochen
und sie können sich vorstellen wie
schwer uns das Feld selbst da haben wir
gesagt in einer Notreserve ja ist es
denkbar um die
versorgungssicherheitsstrom aufrecht zu
erhalten wir haben den Ausbau der Netze
vorangebracht wir haben auf den Weg
gebracht dass die bestandsätze noch in
diesem winterstärker ausgenutzt werden
können wir haben Putin ausgebremst als
er mit Gazprom Germania unsere
Stromkunden ins Minus drücken wollten ja
wir haben gehandelt ein ums andere Mal
haben wir gehandelt was sie bringen
prinzessinformation
ich bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte aber trotzdem nicht versäumen Sie
zu begrüßen an diesem Nachmittag und
jetzt bekommt das Wort
und jetzt erhält das Wort der Kollege
der FDP-Fraktion Conrad Stockmeyer
frau Präsidentin geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der afd-fraktion was sie zum
eigentlichen Titel dieser aktuellen
Stunde zu sagen hatten nämlich den
Blackout verhindern ist dürftig bis
nutzlos
es gibt
Mandatsträger ihrer Partei die ja sehr
sehr gerne nach Osteuropa reisen die
Reisen immer nur ein bisschen zu weit
die Reisen jetzt in Gebiete die Russland
annektieren will und spielen dort
Wahlbeobachter Herr kropalla sie
rekorieren in ihren einleitenden Worten
noch merkwürdiges über Polen dafür bitte
ich Polen an dieser Stelle im Namen des
Hauses um Entschuldigung denn wenn es
ein Land gibt denn wenn es ein Land gibt
das weiß was russische Bedrohung ist und
was es bedeutet im Konzert der Partner
der EU unabhängig davon zu werden dann
ist es Polen
also wenn es darum geht einen Blackouts
zu verhindern dann verlieren sie nicht
wirklich irgendwelche nützlichen Worte
dazu im Gegenteil Herr propala ich
zitiere sie wir brauchen russisches Gas
ich bitte Sie eindringlich diese Aussage
zu überdenken und ich richte diese Bitte
von dieser Stelle aus auch an den
sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten sie
nehmen natürlich überhaupt nicht zur
Kenntnis welche Maßnahmen die
Bundesregierung bereits unternommen hat
teilweise auch mit Unterstützung der
cdu/csu wofür ich mich ausdrücklich
bedanke wir haben im Rekordtempo
lng-ausgleichsgesetz wir weiten Biogas
aus wir treiben die Erneuerbaren voran
es zeichnet sich jetzt auch eine Lösung
für den Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
ab wo wir Freie Demokraten allerdings
auch im Sinne einer Preissenkung
explizit dafür eintreten dass alle drei
bitteschön am Netz bleiben und vor allen
Dingen suchen wir gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen Partnern Lösungen aber das
ist ihnen ja völlig fremd sie ziehen
also nicht nur in der kurzen Frist die
falschen Konsequenzen sondern sie sind
auch völlig damit überfordert
strategisch in der Mittel und langfrist
so zu denken dass Deutschland unabhängig
wird von Energieträgern die von Despoten
geliefert werden und ich sage Ihnen
eines voraus
so schwer die Krise ist und das ist sie
unbestritten so sehr
boosterzieh längst im deutschen
Mittelstand innovative Lösungen die zum
Beispiel im Bereich der gebäudeenergie
sogar mit bestehender Technik durch
digitale Steuerungen zu
Energieeinsparungen zu mehr
Energieeffizienz führen werden die sie
sich gar nicht vorstellen können aber
das ist ja nichts Neues sie können sich
vieles nicht vorstellen
ich sage Ihnen eines
auf meiner Sommertour über die
Marktplätze meiner Heimatstadt Mannheim
kam eine Senioren auf mich zu die mir
sagte wissen Sie wasserstoffmayr ich
habe keine üppige Rente
aber Putin greift nicht nur die Ukraine
an Putin greift unser freiheitliches
demokratisches System an und wir müssen
alle unseren Beitrag leisten damit dass
wir dadurch kommen der Beitrag den ich
leisten kann der ist gering Herr
Stockmeyer aber ich will den gerne
leisten
dieser Senioren die ich vom Namen her
nicht kenne rufe ich von dieser Stelle
aus sie wären würdiger in diesem Hohen
Haus zu sitzen und zu sprechen als die
gesamte afd-fraktion ich danke Ihnen
herzlich
das Wort erhält der Kollege Fabian
gramling für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja wir haben
ein gasproblem und auch ein Stromproblem
und die Erkenntnis ist ja inzwischen in
der Zwischenzeit auch beim
Energieminister angekommen was wir
ausdrücklich begrüßen aber weil die
Regierung eben monatelang gezögert und
auch gezaubert hat kann heute niemand
von uns sagen wie die Situation in
diesem Winter sein wird und ich möchte
damit bei ausdrücklich unterstreichen
dass wir als Unionsfraktion die
Regierung im Ausschuss immer konstruktiv
begleitet haben dass sie auf Fristen
verzichtet haben und dass wir auch
wichtige Maßnahmen zügig mit
vorangebracht haben auch übrigens die
dritte Novelle von NZ zeigt dass die
Regierung immer nachgesteuert hat was
ich in dieser schwierigen Zeit auch
absolut in Ordnung finde
zur Wahrheit gehört aber auch dazu dass
wir bereits im März diesen Jahres
Forderungen aufgestellt haben welche die
Regierung teilweise erst jetzt im
September und damit über sechs Monate
später aufgreift und umsetzt und
verstehen Sie mich verstehen Sie mich
nicht falsch als Opposition haben wir
absolut nichts dagegen wenn Sie Ideen
auch Wochen später von uns umsetzen aber
bereits im März haben wir darauf
hingewiesen dass wir in der aktuellen
Zeit diese Zeit nicht haben dass die
aktuelle Situation diese Zeit diese
Wochen verstreichen lassen ins Land
laufen lassen nicht mehr haben und damit
haben wir wertvolle damit haben wir
wertvolle Zeit verloren
und was unsere mahnenden Worte im März
waren das sind auch unsere mahnenden
Worte jetzt im September nutzen sie
endlich alle Kapazitäten und
Möglichkeiten um auf den Winter
bestmöglich vorbereitet zu sein
und das Zögern und Zaudern der letzten
Monate hat der Versorgungssicherheit in
unserem Land geschadet und das gleiche
Spiel erleben wir in diesen Tagen und
auch in diesen Stunden gerade wenn es um
die gasumlage geht diese Diskussion geht
an der Lebenswirklichkeit der Menschen
vorbei denn schon heute wissen viele
Menschen nicht wie sie überhaupt die
Energierechnung von morgen noch bezahlen
sollen ob sie überhaupt genug Energie
bekommen und auch ob ihr Job im nächsten
Jahr überhaupt noch sicher ist wenn
diese Unsicherheit in der Bevölkerung
wird durch das Chaos durch die Amt durch
das ampelchaos leider nur weiter
befeuert
und das macht die Regierung bis heute
sind wenige Kernkraftwerke zurückgekehrt
dafür ist die gasvorstromung auf einem
neuen Rekordniveau die Menschen sollen
gar sparen im Land während die Regierung
das Gas weiter verfeuert wie noch nie
zuvor die Ampel hat den Sommer über
genutzt um über duschtipps zu
informieren und zu diskutieren statt
sich in der Regierung mal abzustimmen
wie man denn in den Herbst gehen möchte
heute hat das Kabinett beschlossen das
Werbeanlagen von 22 bis 6 Uhr nicht
beleuchtet werden dürfen auch das
Beheizen private Pools soll verboten
sein außer wenn sie dadurch frostfrei
gehalten werden sollen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das alles schön und gut
aber spanien hat bereits vor der
Sommerpause klare Regeln aufgestellt wir
haben jetzt gefördert einen Bund
ländergipfel einzuberufen weil man am
besten an einem Tisch miteinander
spricht als über eine Pressekonferenz
und wir begrüßen ausdrücklich die
Erkenntnis des Ministers das zwei
Kernkraftwerke in der Reserve bleiben
sollen das begrüße ich aus Sicht der
Versorgungssicherheit aber ich frage
mich dann schon was denn auch mit dem
dritten Kernkraftwerk in Niedersachsen
ist das Kernkraftwerk in Emsland muss
Ende des Jahres abgeschalten werden und
weil
und weil Niedersachsen weil wir genug
Windstrom haben kann man auch so sagen
wunderbar wird ein schwimmendes
ölkraftwerk angelandet um genug Strom zu
haben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist absurd das ist absurd
und gerade in der kalten Jahreszeit wenn
wir kein Glück mit dem Wetter haben und
wenn eine dunkelflaute herrscht brauchen
wir ausreichend
grundlastleistung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen im Januar diesen Jahres hat die
klimaredaktion des WDR eine Bilderfolge
entspannt in den Blackout veröffentlicht
mit flapsigen Tipps was man bei einem
Blackout so alles machen könnte diese
Tipps fand ich damals schon deplatziert
weil ein Blackout für unser Land eine
katastrophale Wirkung haben könnte das
war vor dem Angriffskrieg von Putin auf
die Ukraine aber bereits damals gab es
kritische Stimmen dass die
ampelregierung zu wenig für die
Versorgungssicherheit in unserem Land
unternimmt heute ist die Situation
anders es geht um Existenzen es geht um
Jobs es geht um unseren Wohlstand und
deshalb wurde ich die Regierung auf
handeln Sie jetzt bevor es im Winter
nicht nur die Heizung ausgeht sondern
auch das Licht ausgehen kann schließen
sie endlich solidaritätsabkommen mit
unseren europäischen Nachbarn ab und
schaffen sie alle Hürden alle Deckelung
bei den erneuerbaren Energien ab vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
in dieser aktuellen Stunde ist Rubin
mesarosch für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
Blackouts in Deutschland darüber will
die AFD reden und ich finde es ist ein
guter Anlass am Anfang zur Kenntnis zu
nehmen dass eine Partei die immer vor
sich herträgt man dürfe in Deutschland
nicht alles sagen eine Stunde Zeit
bekommt 13 Abgeordnete im Bundestag die
sich zu ihrem Thema äußern und ich muss
sagen ich finde gut dass sie das dürfen
ich finde es nur schade was sie draus
machen nämlich inhaltlich nichts und
dafür stiften sie viel zu viel Chaos und
Panik dass wir gerade in so einer Krise
nicht brauchen
wenn man sich mit ihnen über Blackouts
unterhält muss man gar nicht so viel
über unser Stromnetz verstehen man muss
nicht viel von Technik verstehen man
muss sich vor allem mit Kommunikation
auskennen oder in Ihrem Fall besser bei
Propaganda sie haben Glück ich kenne
mich mit beiden aus mit unserem
Stromnetz und mit Kommunikation deswegen
kauen wir das jetzt beides mal durch
kommen wir kommen wir zu dem technischen
Teil
Blackouts sie werfen das hier immer so
fröhlich durcheinander da drüben steht
jetzt Stromausfälle halten wir erstmal
fest dass Blackouts was völlig anderes
ist als Stromausfälle bei einem Blackout
ich vereinfache das mal für Sie fallen
große Teile im europäischen Netz aus und
man muss verdammt viel dafür tun um das
Netz in den Gebieten wieder zum Laufen
zu bringen das passiert nicht in
Deutschland und es wird ich greife da
jetzt mal meine Erklärung vor auch
diesen Winter nicht passieren ein
Stromausfall ist was anderes das ist auf
lokaler Ebene das auch schlimm und sowas
verursacht immer volkswirtschaftliche
Schäden in Unternehmen kann der Betrieb
nicht weiterlaufen zu Hause ist es
unangenehm aber das ist was anderes und
um auch das vorher zu schicken die Zahl
der Stromausfälle sind in den letzten
Jahren kontinuierlich zurückgegangen
also dieses Chaos und das Deutschland
stürzt nein das sehen irgendwie nur sie
und da muss ich mich schon fragen warum
wenn wenn Sie wenn Sie das als Ideologie
bezeichnen dass ich jetzt zwei Begriffe
trennen Blackouts einerseits
Stromausfälle andererseits will ich
Ihnen warum es wichtig ist auf den
Unterschied zu achten noch mal an einem
Beispiel erklären dass sie begreifen sie
regen sich jedes Mal auf wie
Rumpelstilzchen wenn man sie alle als
Nazis bezeichnet und so geht es dem
handelsüblichen Stromausfall auch der
ärgert sich wenn er als Blackout
bezeichnet wird der Unterschied ist bei
ihnen trifft es leider zu auf den
Stromausfall in Deutschland hat es nicht
zugetroffen dass es ein Blackout ist
worauf ich mich beziehe ist Wissenschaft
worauf sie sich beziehen es irgendein
Typ den sie auf Google gefunden haben
oder in der telegram-gruppe und wenn sie
im Bundestag sitzen wollen dann ist das
der Anspruch den ich an sie Stelle nicht
dass sie irgendwie zu Anstand
zurückkehren oder meine Ideen übernehmen
die Hoffnungen habe ich nicht aber mein
Anspruch ist dass sie sich damit
beschäftigen was sie Realismus nennt und
das tun sie eben leider nicht wir haben
hier zwei Stresstest gemacht das haben
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen gesagt die
doch klar gezeigt haben es gibt keinen
Blackout in Deutschland es wird nicht
dazu kommen was in dem Worst
Case-Szenario wenn alle schlimmen
Situationen zusammen kommen notfalls
notwendig sein kann ist ein Lastabwurf
das ist auch ein blödes Wort aber das
meint dass man gezielt Teile des Netzes
kurzzeitig abschalten muss und das
versuchen wir mit allen Mitteln zu
vermeiden das bereiten wir jetzt vor in
dieser Krise so rechtzeitig wie es nur
geht mit allen Mitteln die sinnvoll sind
und
da beteiligen sie sich eben gar nicht
dran sie erzählen diese Geschichte die
nicht stimmt wir suchen nach der Lösung
dass das löst was tatsächlich nämlich
ein Problem ist was ein Problem sein
könnte und da unterscheiden wir uns
warum haben wir überhaupt das Problem
naja Frankreich ist man hat es eben
gehört hat ein Problem mit
Atomkraftwerken ich fand es interessant
dass sie das als Gelegenheit genutzt
haben hier einzuwerfen wir waren vor
Jahren schon dafür dass Deutschland mehr
Atomkraftwerke bekommt zum Glück haben
wir nie auf sie gehört zum Glück haben
wir nie auf sie gehört Frankreich in
Frankreich laufen gerade 27 von 56
Atomkraftwerken Deutschland hat dieses
Jahr bis zum Sommer schon mehr Strom
exportiert als 2020 und 2021 wir
erzeugen in Deutschland viel Strom das
ist auch eine Tatsache die sie aus
irgendwelchen Gründen nie zur Kenntnis
nehmen natürlich kriegen wir ein Problem
wenn Frankreich ein Problem hat aber wie
gesagt das lösen wir mit Mitteln die
sinnvoll sind und das lösen wir nicht
mit mehr Panik von ihrer Seite diese
Geschichte mit dem Blackouts ist eine
ganz alte Geschichte die haben sie schon
erzählt weil sie gegen die erneuerbaren
Energien waren erneuerbare Energien sind
die günstigste Art Strom zu erzeugen und
mit erneuerbaren Energien können wir ein
Netz sicher am Laufen halten aber zu der
Zeit sind ihre Geschichten nicht
verfangen jetzt erwärmen Sie die wieder
auf auch das wird nicht zum Erfolg
führen wir sagen ganz klar es wird kein
Blackout geben wir tun alles dafür um
den Lastabwurf zu vermeiden und wir
bitten Sie damit aufzuhören Panik zu
schüren wo keine ist und damit ist jetzt
auch gut für heute
die Aktuelle Stunde ist beendet und
vielleicht tut es ja auch allen ganz gut
dass sich die Sitzungen jetzt für
ungefähr ja für ganz genau zehn Minuten
unterbreche es wird ein Klingelton geben
16.30 geht es weiter